this is my dad he foolishly agreed to
let me make him over a drag I was very
surprised when he said yes
are you excited a little bit have you
ever had your makeup done you're ready
to sit here for two hours while we make
you into a woman and now you'll fully
understand what it's like and then to
make my dad into a beautiful gorgeous
woman we have miss Kay I'll go follow
her on Instagram Here I am
[Laughter]
Thanks
[Music]
you look like some pictures so I'm here
today with my father William Akana who
was in the Marine Corps for 23 years and
retired as a lieutenant colonel he's for
some reason agreed to allow me to put
him in drag
so thanks dad I didn't know I'd have a
blood but five facts I asked my dad to
be a drag queen in this video but what I
didn't tell them so I really wanted to
have a heart-to-heart conversation from
one Democrat liberal to a conservative
Republican
today's topic is gonna be the Brett
Kavanaugh confirmation and I'm gonna get
my dad's thoughts on the entire thing do
you don't know anything about the Brett
Kavanaugh confirmation didn't follow it
oh my god dad yeah your video is useless
okay well most can we talk about Trump
do you vote for Trump
I don't know anything about time well
you don't like either choice you just
ignore them no it's your civic duty as
an American to vote when you don't like
our choice you just ignored them both
okay well my dad knows nothing about the
brick have no confirmation so I guess
we'll just discuss politics why are you
a Republican Republican was the
political party which had views that
most closely aligned with my own indoors
the years include minimal
doing things on your own rather than
being helped because I think you learn
more when they're forced to do things on
your own I believe in freedom of
business freedom of speech and all those
things what do you think about the
Republican Party now that they've
confirmed someone into office was over
23 sexual assault allegations against
him and he also nominated a Lutheran
Court Justice who has a ton of sexual
assault allegations against all that one
item by itself does not condemn an
entire party however I believe that
Republican Party has already condemned
itself on numerous accounts where
they've let down the conservative values
of the people that originally made up
the party I'm very disappointed and
disillusioned by the current position of
the Republican Party are you going to
vote on November 6 of course where your
stances on things
fortunately how we vote in elections is
privileged information and you don't
have to make it known so your cleaning
effect v implies that I would be
incriminating myself in some kind of
criminal activity so I'm not pleading
the fifth I'm just standing by my
constitutional rights to privacy you're
a person who shot guns for a very long
time we believed you were a sharpshooter
champion and you taught me how to shoot
guns when I was a kid but we're now
finding that school shootings are a big
thing what do you think is like someone
who's an educated gun owner needs to
happen in order for these kinds of
public mass shootings to stop
responsible used to guns has been a part
of this country since before the
Revolution every family had firearms and
they taught their children how to use
them safely accidents can happen sure
now but a lot of the gun violence that
we hear about is it the gun that caused
it or is because somebody had a problem
psychologically they got into an
emotional altercation with somebody the
fact that a gun was present sometimes
there is an argument there for
the best later this far but is it worth
it giving up with a constitutional right
for those instances which in my opinion
a very very minor minor in terms of
percentage wise of how often it happens
to clarify I don't believe in taking
away guns I think you know the reason we
have guns in our Constitution is very
valid I think it's a it's a safe thing
for some people to have if they are
responsible and if they're
psychologically sound but I think what a
lot of Democrats are trying to do is to
put more sanctions in place so so that
people who are psychologically unsound
can't get a hold of a gun I haven't gone
through the process of getting a firearm
yet as you know I am thinking about it
but from my friends who are firearm
owners even they agree like there should
be more of a background check it she'd
be like the DMV or like you do have to
go retake your test after a certain
amount of time you should have to have
like a psychological evaluation that
it's almost too easy for any person to
get a hold of it without any training
more than a psychological evaluation is
what she just mentioned is training I
recently went through a concealed
weapons carry course and the only reason
that bothered with that was because you
can't open carry in California so in
places where if I did want to take a
firearm I had to use a concealed carry
weapons permit and why would I want to
use those because like if I go out near
the desert and go hiking I would want to
have a weapon with me in case of an
animal attack or somebody comes after me
it provides an immense sense of feeling
safe to have a firearm something like
that not because I wanted to get to the
mall or concert or anything like that
that's in my opinion is totally
unnecessary but in the course of going
through that I was shocked how many
people there wanted to have that license
because they wanted to be able to they
say protect themselves if something
happens but you see me have a good music
they didn't seem serious about it
when we went to the pistol range from
five feet away
you shouldn't had a target about this
wide about this tall and half the shots
are missing the paper if you can't hit a
paper from five feet away you don't
deserve to be shooting a weapon in
public period it also came firearms at
the end of that sure you just had to
make so many hits on paper it wasn't a
hundred percent that's concern it is do
you know about the Miche movement the me
- movement yes a little bit
so the Miche movement was started
because women were very tired of having
to keep silent about sexual assault
sexual harassment cero so there was this
big wave online of women coming out and
accusing like big waves it's sort of
pivoted to where now the main argument
amongst some men is that Oh any woman
can accuse any man at any time of sexual
assault and he's like fired from his job
it ruins his career although it really
doesn't what are your thoughts on like
sexual assault allegations that are
coming out today I have limited
knowledge of the me to movement because
I don't read about it except what I see
on my phone and I read about the news
but from what I've seen women have every
right to speak out about sexual
harassment and sex specially a sexual
assault it's understandable why some
hesitated particularly if they're in a
field like entertainment if you complain
about something like that your career
could end and that in that field but I
think the me - movement would have
helped itself and women better if it
forced a look at applying the law a lot
of the complaints that I've read about
about the me - movement is the hearsay
whereas it's something we're taking in a
legal direction you got to deal with
evidence
there has been some like the broad
Turner case for example he was sentenced
I think when - six months in jail for
raping a woman there were there were
witnesses there who saw that he raped
her
and so I think a lot of women are really
discouraged today because the law is not
backing us up when we do talk about it
and unfortunately with the way that
so it goes it's like you don't want to
talk about it your instinct is to like
take a shower immediately afterward to
forget about it your brain literally
doesn't want to remember the details of
that and so blowing forward to like the
police and all that is not actually
encouraged not instinctual for women in
my opinion men and women are not the
same they just want okay so the legal
system is dominated by men a better
solution is it's not a short-term
solution but is to get more women on the
bench so that you can have more views
from both sides
on cases like that in deciding on
sentences a woman judge might be able to
better appreciate the magnitude of the
offense I'm not saying that it's okay
that men are dim viewed in those things
but I think it's a fact of life that
they don't view things the same they
grew up different so as a society they
have to fix that by better integration
of the genders um cool is there anything
else you want to say about politics in
general dad yes thank you Squarespace
for sponsoring today's episode
Squarespace has beautiful award-winning
templates and have no patches installs
or upgrades ever Plus 24-hour customer
service if you have a question and 3
a.m. if you go to squarespace.com such
an a' to start your free trial today and
use the offer code ana for 10% off at
checkout this is my dad and drag back
vote